[拍手]
re
[音楽]
[拍手]
地中
私たちが進めませ
あなたは宇宙へ展開終わったことがありますか
私はあります
落ち込んだたちの入り口夜空を見上げた時もこの星あ家中が5名に壮大に広がってよい
ち
行ってみたいな思ったことがあります
きっとなる子も死ぬまでに一度は宇宙へ
てみたいと
思ったことがあるんじゃないでしょうか
そして通して家へ行きたいか
と問われた時の答えに一つは
この地球美しい家
世界一宇宙一の設計を目にしない可能てはないでしょう
でも残念ながら今誰もが宇宙へいるわけではありません
きっと多くの人は諦め
と思います
でも何故でしょ考えたことはありますか
ここで皆さんに聞いてみたいと思います
あなたが右中指を諦めている今何ですか
この3つの選択肢の中から選んでみてください
a は宇宙へは訓練されて十字こうしていけない
ちょっと一時当社はなれないかなーって思ってるんで
家名は行っております
いいわお金があったら打出駅
でもお金そんな9で1名はいけない
しーわーやる違うのランドできるっしょ
でもちょっとスランプでやる気ない運営うちはいけないかなぁって言う人
じゃあちょっと手を挙げてみてくれますか
今への一つん
ありがとうございますいいましたん
ありがとうございます c のショッ
ありがとうございます
だいたいローレ g 者が亀があれば宇宙できる
思ってるんですね
そうなんですよ今お金があれば宇宙できるんです
実際に7人もの民間人の人が
国際宇宙ステーションの宇宙力をしたことがあるんです
うらやましいですよねん
実際3つの選択肢が示すよおうちは簡単にはイカができる場所ではありません
極限の環境で神が死んでしまうかもしれません
そして大量お金が必要です
サラの相当な覚悟や有機會必要なんじゃないでしょうか
宇宙は魅力的なんだけどそれをその魅力を堪能するためた木にはあまりにも過酷で
だんだん高い5
次回に74億人もの人がいる中で
宇宙いたことがある人は550認定
少ないですよねん
宇宙飛行士もお金を家でもない私たちをとって
うちは手の届かない存在
雲の親もそうなんです
でも
その状況が変わっているとした
人が宇宙近づいているとした
宇宙とあなたの距離が出回っているとしたら
皆さん信じますうーん
あたしたちと宇宙戸田タイの牛を一つは
お金を一緒ね
お金がかかってしまう要因の一つわー
家へ行くために必要なロケットの打ち上げコストが高いからです
どうしてだかいうとそもそも打ち上げ解説少ない
それでコストが高いのは事業が伸びなかったんです
でも今はその調子が崩れています
新しい企業の出現によってコストが下がってるんです
ではどれぐらい下がって通りません
従来1キロのもの第1回水1リットル分のものを1名真には100万円を買ってました
1 l 100万円を取ってくれかいう感じなんですけど
いっても今は何とっ
30万よねー
千代30万
10代よ70%オフのポケットが今坂が飛んでるんです
セールです
さらにすごいことに
なぜのポケットは
1回飛ばしアートを使い捨てだったんですけど最近のロケットは
口して再利用いきます
何回も同じを検討を使って
ものを宇宙へ運べるようになるのでコストがどんどん下がっていきます
最終ぴコーナー5キロのものを1万円で家で運べるようになると考えられます
1キロ1万円いい従来の99%分
だいたい体制
私だから54万円見えちゃいます
あなたは前行きました
今までの宇宙開発は国が主催で行われていました
ん
でも今は新しいアイデアを持った人が宇宙開発するピエゾに続々と参入していてもはや
国主導の打ち返すから脱却しています
宇宙に行くにはお金がかかるっていう私たちは常識をこの人たちは自分たちの手で
変えようとしているです
ではアマチュアの世界はどうでしょう
アマチュア代表格である私たち学生は変化しているでしょうか
この宇宙開発の家族は所詮ことの話
学生は別
いいえ違います学生も
うち近づいていてするん
学生が到達できる領域も増えてです
ん
さあ皆さん覚えてますか
最初に見せた写真ですねー
実はこれを撮影したのほかでもない
学生ですね
この者そんな2011年に来られるのはなく生が撮影しました
うんっ
グライダー宇宙開発地なんとん
私たちの団体のた場合です
謎とは学生のうちからの宇宙に行く学生の子様で家を作成することに挑戦ニ長調選手
です
私は
この写真はー
スペースバルーンという通常を使って撮影されました
スペースパターンは頑丈な風船のことで
控除30km まで飛行することができます
コード30キロは飛行機の3枚の高さ
宇宙飛行士が暮らしている国際宇宙ステーションの10分の1のコードです
私は
ラフトの創立メンバーでスペースたルーンのプロジェクトエンジニアやプロジェクト
リーダーとして5年間取り組んできました
ラフトはまだまだ切実なはないと反対
この5年は挑戦の連続なんかのランカーを出版しました
a できるのはこれくらいか
あきらめちゃあきらめかけそうになった時も
たくさんありましたでもそれを乗り越えたとき
学生でも宇宙観や使っている
アクセルを宇宙に届くんだと確信しました
ん
この車掌が2011年に撮影されたものです
今から2016年8月
去年の竜人発生された動画をみなさんに見てもらったと思う
これです
めちゃくちゃ綺麗じゃないですか
実はこれはスローじゃないです
実際のスピードで岩中れています
たった5年たった5年で本当に宇宙飛行士撮影した感じは武井壮
宇宙船に付いたカメラで捉えたかのような映像を学生で撮影できるようになったんです
学生を進化しています私たちは宇宙
近づいてないです
でももっともっと近づいています
この動画はただの釣果じゃないです
300復讐と投函というものです皆さん
このようなオークルをつけたん
男をつけた人も高されませんかあのん
スマホ方を搭載すると
あるで自分がこの映像を中にいるかのような映像際混乱
できる
この動画をこのホームでつけると
なんと自分が宇宙に彼らの体型
宇宙湯が生きるんです
そしてなんとこれは
無料です
が youtube で公開されています
私たちは今無料で宇宙に行けます
中傷してなくてもお金がなくてもやる気がなくても宇宙に行けるんです
この工具を使ったら vr で宇宙へ
できます
今日私はうちはもう遠くない場所ということを伝えたかったんですが少しはこのワーク
ワークを伝えることができましたかね
うん
でも今日私話した事は今起きていることのほんの少しでしたんです
これから宇宙できるのもっと今日の関心を持ってほしいと思います
そして家がもう遠くないということを変えてもう一つみなさんを伝えたいことがあり
ます
それは近づいた家を使っていませんかということです
今まで宇宙開発を関わって来なかった子達の積極本参加して新しい
柔軟アイディアとまだまだ未知数で無限の可能性を秘めている宇宙が組みあわさ
どうなると思いますか
きっともっともっと宇宙が身近な場所になって火星や月にも行けるようになって
珠玉旅行で宇宙旅行にとくらい
ウチがお疲れましょうなぁ
誰の家に行けるようになった時世界中の人が家お話
世界中の人が宇宙を使ってどんなの抑止
それが ajico してどんどんどんどんされてくる
わくわくしませんかん
でもそうなるのはこれからでそうするとは私はあなたです
だから一緒に宇宙奉献してみませんが
ありがとうございます
[拍手]